luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome
back to another episode of the lehigh plan
show powered by the vc firm icon plus capital as
sponsored by blockfi so actually some amazing news
blockfy have now increased their interest rates so
i think you can get up to nine and a half percent
on your stable coins um of course per
adam so that is really cool so i've left
a link for you in the description in the comments
section so check that out i think you want to get
some money when you sign up so that's cool um
and also guys do not forget if you are watching
on youtube please hit the subscribe button and
hit the like button so you never miss a video
so joining me today um it's gonna be pretty
exciting actually because i often find that
this space is very american-centric but today
it is all about the brits so joining me is the
british cryptocurrency mainly bitcoin exchange
coin corner guys welcome to the show how you doing
thanks for having us it's good to have you
all here so i think the best thing to do
is to go around and understand who everyone
is who do we have here so danny we'll start
with you hey i'm danny um co-founder and ceo uh
hi guys molly head of marketing at coin corner
i'm zach um tech lead here at clunk
corner and i'm david the accountant
head office i love it well it's good to meet
you all because i obviously i've met i've
spoken with danny and molly loads of times
but i haven't messed up met the rest of the
team so it's good to chat to you so before we
jump into everything for those that don't know
who coin corner um is just give us the the basic
understanding of coin corner and what you guys do
yep so we are a um bitcoin exchange um
at the core of i guess um focus around
uk focus and so we've been around since
2014 uh founded back in 2014 and um
operating in 45 sort of countries around the world
now um and continuing to look to expand and based
here in the alaman um still all here in the office
i know the rest of the world is still quite remote
um but as you can see we are all back in the
office and having some time fortunate yeah i've
been seeing um molly your your tick tock videos
um saying good morning to everyone i love it
it's so good yeah well i basically i don't know i
just wanted to show people who we were um because
i think sometimes encrypted can be a bit of a
faceless space and i think i don't know whether
i'm just a bit biased but i think we've got quite
a good team here who are actually quite funny
even even you do yeah um so yes i just wanted to
create little videos to show people who we are
hopefully that helps like build some trust as
well with you know everything in the space but
uh yeah good i'm glad you're enjoying them yeah no
i think it's great because a lot of the time you
know twitter is so anonymous um it's where we all
live and putting a face to um companies and names
and things like that adds so much credibility
um but danny you mentioned that you're expanding
and you absolutely are because you had the coin
floor acquisition so can you tell us about this
yeah sure um so yeah we've um three weeks ago
i kind of made the announcement that we've um
acquired coin floor uh coin floor the longest
running uk bitcoin exchange um we've known the
guys for quite some time they launched a little
bit before us um back in the day and obviously met
them at conferences and always kept communication
open with the guys um i guess our visions
between the two companies have always been very
similar very bitcoin centric and bitcoin focus
um hopefully same sort of morals and same
sort of direction of where we wanted to take
um coin corner is effectively where they wanted
to take coin flow so and i think the acquisition
has come nicely in terms of um allowing uh coin
corner to continue coin floors vision um of where
they wanted to take on floor and bitcoin uh as a
whole so um we're very um proud happy to have uh
bring the customers coin floor customers on board
now as well um and welcome them into coin corner
and hopefully help carry on i guess
the legacy point flawless left behind
um being the longest uk exchange and um
one first i think it's an incredible uh
journey they went on and obviously we've been
through similar journey and know the pains and
pressures that you go through you mentioned
having this similar vision what is that vision
depends on how long you got yeah we got time and
tell us what's the vision what's the whole you
know what's the the mission and the the idea i
think for us at the minute um we are focused as
mentioned there um around bitcoin and trying to
drive bitcoin products and having that as the
the forefront we are i know the coin floor crowd
and coin themselves uh they are very bitcoin only
um yeah they are in that direction um we've
even had we do have um ethereum and like or an
on-coin corner which we've had for a few years
and we kind of added them years ago but we've
uh since the demand for them wasn't really
there in comparison to bitcoin it was always
the altcoins made up of about 10 of our volume
whereas 90 percent has always been bitcoin uh
so we've always focused on bitcoin um regardless
of that but that in addition has meant they've
just kind of sat there in the background and we've
kind of um turned our focus or kept our focus on
bitcoin we have had a lot of slack from some of
the coin floor customers coming over that we're
not bitcoin only obviously really apologize for
that um for that crowd without a doubt um but
you know that's just the way our system uh our
way our business has been uh built initially um
whether that was a mistake to add altcoins back
in the days anyone's anyone's um opinion i guess
at that point no i think each to their own if they
want to buy bitcoin they can buy bitcoin you know
but yeah i think obviously bitcoin
has a real world use case has the um
has a purpose i guess um touch on
something that's i guess live today and
active today in terms of the shiba inu oh
my gosh you know that that's really bad
this is just kind of helping a
short answer to your question uh
you know bitcoin has a real world use case and
purpose and it has the the foundations and the
the true technology and everything and makes it
what it is today whereas you have the likes of the
sheba e news and the dogecoins and things like
you know they pop up and exactly you obviously
asking everybody what she being actually does and
if you just read through the answers you know goes
up clearly at least it goes up though because
like i saw i saw a funny tweet um i'm not gonna
name any particular coins but i saw a funny tweet
of somebody saying you know hear a list of all
the meme coins and they had some like reputable
coins in them right and then somebody just said
well no that that one doesn't go up um
at least like doge and she would eat
it go up so i was like fair enough um but
let's let's talk let's just say let's talk
about the market so because it's been a really
crazy week um yeah shiba inu was up over 150
um in the last week of course bitcoin hit new
highs so um dave or danny whoever wants to jump in
on this um what do you think really just sparked
this ball run because some people were saying
you know that's it mark yasuko for example i spoke
with him and he wasn't that convinced that we were
going to see new highs and yet we did i think
the etf's played a big part in it i would say
in terms of that was last week we saw a bullish
one from from that announcement that they were
all coming live and then we saw that the new high
and a bit of a bounce off that i think that that
did play a part in my eyes yeah yeah i think so
because the etf you know broke records was it the
second largest first day etf and broke a
18 year old gold record and the whole uh
allowing an etf gives huge access to people
that couldn't buy bitcoin before or restricted
markets that were restricted have now been opened
through it so of course i was going to pump them
on price i think the anticipation to it as well
uh drove the price um i think generally though
so i'm surprised at mark ciusco's comments to be
fair on that in terms of yeah i'll reach a high
and i do quite like a lot of marks uh
no he's great yeah he's he's good he's
i think he's probably our biggest
mount socks fan that's amazing
tweets pretty much every friday with our socks on
um which is always nice to see um but he's always
very bullish so i'm quite surprised that his
his comments are um but i think for me the way
again playing off history and
everyone looks at history uh to see
where we expect this ball runs to move towards and
you know 2013 and 2017 they lasted a year in real
in terms of like the bullish periods and during
that year you have your ups and downs and you
have the early spikes and the other movements
and it kind of gets things prepped and ready
and then you have a little bit of a lull and a
down period and we've for us coming from corners
perspective in terms of um volumes and new
customer signups and things like we can see the
trends of what i'm moving and we've seen since
we had a bit of a crazy period from january to
april should we call it april may then you know it
dies off during june july august september started
to come back again and now october's starting to
pick up a little bit more again um so this is it's
pretty much the exact same um time scales as what
we saw in 2017 and then we saw obviously what we
saw in 2017 was october picked up november when
started to move and then december went crazy um so
i know you can't always predict something going
forwards based off history and but i think with
that in mind the harvard impacts the uh the way
the the sentiment of the industry as a whole
in terms of you know companies coming on
board you've just seen mastercard jump on
and yeah announcements we're seeing paypal and not
people sorry um obviously i've gotten gone live
as well but um tesla looking like they're gonna
start accepting bitcoin again um you know these
the etfs kicking off as they've touched
on their the sentiment again has shifted
towards a much more positive and bullish
sentiment uh in general as a whole um how
accurate plan b is model because he's like well
now he's 63 by the end of the month throughout
what does plan b say doesn't he say bye
like he doesn't like 200k by q1 or q2 or
something next year is that what he said
he's he put the yeah so it's a hundred and
it's quite range so there's no real figures yeah
in all fairness we did one uh back in june which
stated the um end-of-month figures of what he
expected bitcoin to be equal to or greater than
um and he's hit the mail on the head to the
thousand every month since then um so this
month for october was 63k so and we're at 61
at the minute we've got three days together
but he says that i think he says that he expects
this bull market to continue for the next six
months which takes us to around april so what do
you think do you think this is the last leg now
um very different i i i'll let somebody else talk
you um i would um again looking at history i
would have always had in my head you know that the
ballroom might have another three months to four
months maybe in it in terms of price movement and
back to a new all-time high however knowing
the way the industry's moved and the strength
and the foundations it's built along the way
now and especially this last year and there's
no reason that the ballroom cut or the bullish
period i guess rather than a ballroom bullish
period can continue on for yeah six months nine
months right yeah if etfs are only just kicking
in will would be the change of the four-year
cycles for bitcoin uh i don't know it's worth
remembering we're still pretty low in google
trends terms we hit an all-time high i think
google trends was still about 30 weren't they
yeah it was whereas the huge ball in december
17 wasn't it the google translate would go up
to 90 when it was hitting 20. so you've got
to think it still looks like attention's
not been fully grabbed even though we're
at a new all-time high and that they could go a
lot further yeah even from mainstream media you've
had much from them you just see more food really
like putting out more energy foot the other day
why do you think they do that though it's so funny
because i i think i did see something which said
what does it cost like a hundred dollars
of electricity to buy a cup of coffee with
bitcoin i think that was the headline i can't
remember i saw the 5 000 pound crash headline
which was ridiculous um why do you think it's so
um it's it's hostile and also they just missed
the point is it just pure ignorance and um yeah
just ignorance and terrible journalism or do you
think there's like an ulterior motive here they
just don't like it and they want to squash it
yeah how they report it's
a headline rather isn't it
anytime you would do it like crash or anything
it's just like all right what's happened there
it's just that animalistic instinct to see what's
going on yeah but that's how i think like the
times does it really badly yeah it's like every
bitcoin article the times right it's exactly the
same follows the same format they always mentioned
you know satoshi and all that it's just it's lazy
journalism yeah a lot of that as well
as like from an seo perspective benefit
yeah it's like they're just yeah if you focus
too much on seo then that's why every uh is
which is what you are seeing i think yeah the
mainstream media is lazy in that respect i think
in terms of what they're reporting what you
just touched on there the um hundred dollar
100 pounds whatever it was i think 100 yeah
everything's dollars yeah um what was it for
every drink i think every cup of coffee i think
coffee um yeah in that respect but again this
comes back to education a little bit but you know
they are blindly or choosing almost i think or i
feel to ignore the education that's around it but
why facts because it makes for a better headline i
guess is the way that it is um which is difficult
we i know we've had this conversation before
though in terms of education um it makes our
lives hard because we're constantly having to work
on satan fight against them sort of uh
journalistic um clickbait headlines and the
content that they're putting out there and we've
we've did our own research in terms of that um
with the lightning network on top of bitcoin
and how many transactions you can make um per
um kilowatt hour but in terms of carbon output
that you would put from bitcoin in comparison
to real-world products and real-world things like
orange juice glass of orange juice is equal to z11
lightning transactions and that's including the
whole of the bitcoin network in there as well so
when you actually take things properly into
consideration and weigh things up in terms of
compare that to real world things that people
used to like a glass of glass of orange juice
and you can start to understand that
you know this is a non-issue um but
it doesn't matter calling it a non-issue
and telling everybody the real facts doesn't
create good headlines it's also much easier to
publish if an article has been publishing before
so like no one does their own research in terms
of transactional stuff they literally just copy
it down so like for like five years everyone was
using that same item called the same article it
was the same book yeah yeah and even though it's
proven like it's just easy because they've got
multiple sources to validate and that's how they
validate what was the book called of bananas the
uh that was about how much electricity emails
used was yeah um so for the last five to ten years
all journalists have been referencing this one
book for the amount of energy that emails take
up well that was brought it was released in
2011 but there was a new book released in 2020
but even since the new book was released with
new updated numbers journalists and everyone
are still using the old numbers and still
putting out that content so we did our um
sort of research project we did was using the
new numbers and the new content from the book
and to update everything which was in favor more
so than for emails and things like that which is
better as we expect as time goes on as technology
improves uh the electricity usage becomes less
and less for these these products um but yeah
the media are not still using that and choosing
to ignore it i guess no one sat there all day
sending emails worried about all the electricity
or even just you know when you go on holiday and
you leave the fridge on you know the fridge is on
all day even when you go out leave the lights
on and things like that nobody talks about it
christmas lights but we won't go into that
but what i do think would be a great headline
which would be very pro bitcoin would be
something like um bitcoin could be the end
of banks you know like what is pro bitcoin why
can we have a headline like that anyway so i
often think there's something kind of i don't know
an ulterior motive in my personal opinion but um
you know you're always having to come up
against something and obviously in the us
they had the whole infrastructure bill which um
obviously wasn't very cryptocurrency friendly
at all um so what's the situation like in the
uk i do remember that the fca a few months ago
um put 11 000 pounds into educating people
about the dangers of cryptocurrency so
have you had any issues with the fca um that was
the 11 million wasn't it that um yeah educating on
warning people i guess in terms of uh the risk
of cryptocurrency investments and purchases
um we've got nothing but to say
about this we haven't loved them
and no we i think regulation everywhere around
the world it's coming the industry and people will
um for the most part you know you kind of have
to accept that and that's the way the world works
and the laws i know you can try and not rebel but
you can try and fight against that such um and we
do our our part with the regulators with the
the aleman fsa with the uk fca we try and even
further afield and when we're communicating
with them and trying to work with them
it's about what can make them
comfortable in terms of how they protect
um some of it for me the protecting consumer
is a different question to like the anti-money
laundering side of things um but the from the
anti-money laundering perspective from the fca
fsa and so on um it's what makes them comfortable
and is still able to create um a realistic
business i guess a business model and an industry
uh for the bitcoin industry in the crypto industry
um you always have to kind of meet in the middle
somewhere with them and that's i guess what we've
done over the years and we've tried to push back
where he's needed and you know the regulator's
the other day are not that educated on these
industries that they go into to to regulate um
so they have to and they we appreciate that they
appreciate that they have to take guidance from um
the industry as a whole and that's what they they
often do and it's just a case of communication and
making sure we can um meet in the middle somewhere
of course obviously things always can go too far
the bit license was probably a prime example of
that in new york um and still is that they still
don't seem to be budging and seems to be getting
worse recently um but that's i guess uh them
overreaching um um whether that's a a wall street
um big bank uh kind of poking the regulator there
to say look clamp down on this industry or not
i don't know you've got to remember the banks
are highly regulated themselves so yeah it's it's
almost like a lever it has to be 11 playing field
as we we're talking about that's competition with
them because you can't expect the fta to regulate
them so highly and then ignore this growing
business that's the bank's argument effectively
and that's where they're poking the regulators
they go and look at these guys and then you know
the the bit license in new york is probably the
one the only one that's gone over the top uh an
overreach um they've been overreaching in terms
of what they've been doing and there has been
cases where they're trying to like people like
like by using nuts there's this square taking a
roundhold like using traditional existing frames
existing frameworks yeah existing frameworks
for the new industry like to say because
they're not they don't understand the full
ins and outs of this industry of how bitcoin
works essentially and we have had cases where
we've had some government organizations and
he come in here to actually educate them so
we are actually responsible for spreading that
message and it's probably part of what coin corner
tries to do is put education at the front of what
we do in terms of trying to get the message across
and this isn't a scary industry this is actually
some a product that can help a lot of people
i think what always just blows my mind is that
you have people who have never even um touched
a cryptocurrency in their life not that you can
physically touch it but you know people who have
never even held a cryptocurrency um making rules
and regulations um about it and particularly
in america um you know talking about taxing um
unrealized um unrealized gains which which just
really blew my mind um do do you have any thoughts
on on that guy's taxi unrealized games it's crazy
that's one it's just crazy you can't really yeah
i think it got thrown out yesterday right did it
it's a target there's you know more wealthy
people with a lot of property that you know
going up in value and that they aren't
getting taxed on in any way shape or form but
um it's crazy to think you could actually
levy a tax on someone would they haven't got
they haven't realized that the capital wasn't
released to then pay the tax bill it's crazy
so it did get thrown out quite quickly um the the
worry that people have in the uk is then bitcoin's
obviously subject to capital gains tax and the
budget announcement yesterday the capital gains as
people were expecting a movement in it in terms
of the allow the allowable you basically got an
allowance in the uk about 12k that says you you
earn up to this in a game and after that you pay
taxes on it but um people are expecting that
to be sharply reduced in terms of we know that
uk government have to pay back an awful lot
of code good measures and but it looks like
they're actually freely spending and capital gains
wasn't touched yesterday in terms of in terms of
the allowances so there's the thresholds on
maybe the threshold so what is it you get 12
um i don't know because i don't sell so what
you'll get yeah it's an option for people just
so what is it you get 12 you get 12 000 pounds
um free not taxed and then what is it isn't it
like 20 or something after that yeah there's a
higher and lower rates the higher rates 20 and
it's different for houses and secondary properties
and bits and pieces but it is something that you
have to be aware of if you are trading bitcoin
you do have to keep a record of your pool so it's
a something that you just if you keep good records
most people probably well actually nowadays with a
bullish one people probably do have to think about
that threshold but historically they haven't had
to yeah or you just don't sell you know you take
a loan out against your bitcoin um and then you
build generational wealth so you guys are offering
loans soon is that right soon yes yeah yeah we um
got approved in the element for um the loan
license so we've got that um we will be launching
hopefully before the end of the year um with
the bitcoin back loans uh which will have more
detail on that i guess as um nearer the time um
but yeah approved and ready to go just um coin
floor acquisitions kind of took priority and the
other products will be coming soon i have to do it
like i've never i haven't actually taken a loan
out yet against my bitcoin but i will have to do
it um every i like all the cool kids are doing it
now i'm joking yeah it's like one of those things
you have like unchained capital and all these
all these different companies um offering that
service which is really cool um but yeah you
you also have the um you've also integrated
the lightning network so uh more and more people
are are doing transactions um on the lightning
network which is really really interesting i think
it's actually allowed the the transaction fees to
drop on the base layer so talk to me about this um
how can people use the lightning network with you
you're all the lightning people i suppose
it helps back to what we're talking about
the starting times of our vision so i know danny
and me specifically always tried to keep up with
the technical side of bitcoin we were right we
were early ourselves personally in the lightning
network and we always plan to integrate just
have to wait for the network itself to mature
and then when we thought it was a good time we um
we integrated into the exchange so it just allows
um customers to make use of basically we offer
free deposits and withdrawals online network and
just allows users to come on use either on chain
or lightning in one wallet system so it's very
very simple to users they can send out over the
line network or send in over the lightning network
micro transactions all that jazz yeah i think part
of this as well is that we introduced lightning in
the january this year wasn't it yeah january this
year um and that was our first stepping stone you
know that's not the final form and there's still
lots of development and lots of products to come
on the back of this uh we have something that
will be coming in the next uh for end of november
um which um we are you guys are you going to
be at uh coinfest like are you i have no idea
what what's the date for is the end of november
or beginning of november end of november unsure
i'm sure 25th 26th 27th down about that time i'm
not sure i haven't decided um so we'll hopefully
be there and we're hoping to announce uh something
there at that point which is all related to the
lightning side of things and developments we're
doing um so that'll hopefully be very exciting uh
something that looking forward to the and that's
one of the little projects around lighting so now
we have lightning capabilities within the system
we're able to build various things on top of that
and zach um more so than myself these days at the
minute uh has been working around all sorts of
um the even the going forwards to the layer
threes and doing um forgot the name uh that
was working on the other week what are the layer
threes hang on layer three what impervious which
was um did you potentially get the webpage live
uh no no not quite uh impervious is basically a
layer three on top of lightning which is
essentially like a decentralized internet
so it allows uncensored communication between
several nodes so that's still very early just like
the lightning's very early but we've been playing
around with that as well and i suppose just going
back to the lightning network i think el salvador
has been a big eye-opener to a lot of people
obviously historically i think me and danny have
obviously been into the lighting network from
pretty much the beginning we had several people
tell us it's you know fake tech and that kind
of thing and then to see what's happening in
el salvador which wouldn't be possible without
the lining network it's kind of proven all those
they say is wrong and just giving everyone more
conviction in terms of you know this is
the future of payments on top of bitcoin
um it works yes there's issues but you know we're
still alien bitcoin we're still early in line
so wait i want to i still want to go back to the
layer three so what's it called again impervious
hang on i'm still here let me just hit my camera
my camera goes off every 30 minutes it's really
annoying unless i hit it um okay so layer three um
so so that's like the internet what does that mean
so let's so you've got we've got bitcoin obviously
layer one um obviously these things have been
built on top and you've got lightning on top of
that um and then now somebody's doing something
called impervious which is now being built
on top of lightning and using the lightning
network and lightning layer to um communicate
via their own protocol that they've created now
um and that is allowing i think was it just this
week was it last week they announced the browser
that they're doing yeah they're answering
they're building a browser which will you
know sit on top of this so like just your normal
internet browser but instead of visiting websites
um you'll be visiting impervious nodes which
is using the lightning as the rails underneath
so you can you can basically host
websites on that and it's kind of like
uncensorable you know you've got issues like in
china at the moment they restrict the internet and
north korea and all that kind of thing it's kind
of like decentralizing the internet as we know it
so how do you access it this
browser that they're building
it just like i guess the minute you say like
you download chrome for example you would just
download um the impervious browser for example
and you would then what the extension or no
it's a new browser it's a brand new action
and then you would enter any url in there
that's on the impervious network on the line
network and it would allow you to effectively load
that website based off other people around the
world serving it to you via the lightning network
interesting concepts and yeah it's very it's
very much proof of concept at the moment not
not in full production for people to use but um
it's exciting yeah it's just another one of the
things you have to keep you know we have you've
got your bitcoin and bitcoin has its value layer
the investment angle and the product in itself the
store of value store wealth we're going to call it
and then we've then got the lighting network now
which is becoming more of the actual payments
side of things and the money movement
and moving money around the world
um obviously we're now having quite a focus on
the moving the money around the world peace and
enlightening side and working on lots of things
around that but then of course as that matures
and that moves on in the industry and more things
happen um moore's develops and then we will see
these these layer threes and even layer twos
i'll interact um and you know it's this talk of
thinking further further down the line you talk
of the cbd season that the um so all these central
bank digital currencies that are potentially
coming out and as long as they all stick to
some form of um same real sense same protocol in
some respects and make them all interoperable with
each other um eventually maybe you'll be able to
interact with bitcoin's lightning network with
the bank of england's gbp stablecoin that they
create um in a decentralized interoperable model
yeah i was going to say you've got to hope that
they look at something like that eventually
because although if they don't they are just
creating they're recreating you know you're
reinventing the wheel if they don't look to that
um the advantage over making that interoperability
and with the rest of the currencies around the
world whether they be decentralized bitcoin
cryptocurrencies or whether they be other central
banks currencies um then you know you want them
interoperable with each other so they can interact
and move things around of course they might feel
like loses control and that's a decision they're
gonna have to make and see how that plays out but
if they don't do that are they just reinventing
the wheel of what we already have in the system
now so yes yeah is yeah so that's your answer
you need to make it an open network that everyone
can communicate with the way bitcoin is moving
things yeah i mean reinventing the wheel plus
diminished privacy and more control um but yeah
i mean it's going to be interesting to see how
to see how it plays out like cbdc's are coming i
think what was really funny actually was um so um
this cbn central bank of nigeria just launched the
e naira this week and then the app just crashed so
i i don't really like i don't like um cbdc's
at all and so when the app crashed i was like
that's good um but but i mean it's interesting all
this um development that's happening on bitcoin
because often a lot of the development that
we see in this space is happening on ethereum
so do you think that eventually we will get to
a place where bitcoin is doing what ethereum is
doing um you know i know i've seen conversations
about um nfts on bitcoin and things like that
yep yeah i think so um nfts on bitcoin is possible
it's been done several years ago it's just i feel
like most of the developers on bitcoin are focused
on developing rather than marketing um so it often
goes unheard i think yeah i think it's real world
products i think over um current hype without
wanting to insult anyone um i think current
hype around nfc's and you know we've seen it
all through the different cycles and
altcoins we've had um blockchain this
blockchain that we've had um icos we've
had d5 we've now kind of been nft territory
um and these these height periods come with the
next new fad um that people jump onto and um don't
get me wrong in some respects sometimes it brings
and attracts people to the industry as a whole
and that can work in a positive manner um
sometimes we say um but obviously they're not
solving real world problems you know some of them
may eventually find a use case where they can
solve a real world problem which would be amazing
and great and i look forward to seeing them once
um but again with the noise and that's what
we've done at coin corner is trying to not
let that noise distract us and try and focus on
what we believe has that long-term uh sustainable
um lifespan of a product and a service um which is
bitcoin and the things being developed around that
um in terms of the uh a good way maybe to
explain or to put this um on bitcoin with
the smart contract side so we've got um simplicity
is one of the things that's been worked on um by
quite a few of the core devs uh which allow for uh
easier smart contract platform basically on top of
bitcoin um so that is moving and coming and okay
that's still very least well not very early stages
we're kind of moving with that a little bit now
um so short answer is yes there's smart contracts
pieces coming into bitcoin already you know
lightning in this in itself is the smart contracts
on bitcoin um so they are there and they've been
used but they're being used in real world use
cases rather than creating jpegs sold for millions
of dollars um eventually though the way out the
best way for me to describe this eventually you
know five years ten years down the line once
bitcoin um bitcoin has that strong foundation and
that these truly decentralized strong foundation
um that is the key thing for me and that's one
of the things that is um very very beneficial
from a bitcoin perspective and if we look at
the likes of even ethereum um the cardanos the
dots whatever or the ones they've got around these
days uh lose track of how many there is and what
they're doing but they are built with very much um
some form of centralization for a lot of the time
and um often the the tech you know we saw just
last night was it the financial something or other
that flash loan that got robbed for a couple of
hundred million dollars or whatever it was um and
nothing but that usually uh books in the smart
contract piece and so on but you know there's
they're moving quickly and breaking things
and losing money whereas bitcoins move slowly
and build an incredible foundation to build
on five to ten years time you're a new company
wanting to build some form of smart contracts
basis on a decentralized platform who do you
pick the one with the strong foundations or the
ones that keep moving quickly and breaking things
and eventually you know everybody will come
back to or come to the um strong foundation
that you want to build a long-term business on
not something that's going to be building quickly
breaking and killing your business um so i think
long term that's kind of the way i would envision
it going and i think bitcoin will slowly um remove
a lot of the altcoins use cases it already has
you know most all coins don't really have a use
case like this sorry i've gone heavier to help
them no it's okay i think i think it's going to be
um really interesting to see what happens hang on
just bear with me bear with me one second somebody
has just entered my apartment but everyone
bear with me one sec somebody has just
entered my apartment hang on this is very
interesting because it's live and there's
nothing i can do so just give me one sec
yeah sorry i've got heavy on that with any more
to add to the um how much you hate old coins yeah
spoke on behalf um it gosh that was crazy do
you know what i heard them knocking when you
were on there and i thought they'd leave it was
housekeeping i'll tell you i'll just act to be
honest and tell you what happened i actually burnt
something in the oven yesterday um and so i burnt
something in the oven and so i i told the airbnb
i needed them to come clean it so now they're just
banging on the door to clean it but 10 minutes
okay um anyway yeah i think i think it's really
interesting um i think that um right now there
are a lot of altcoins um slowly losing value
and i definitely agree with you in that sense um
and i think that one of the things which really
annoys me about that kind of part of this industry
is that a lot of companies just create these coins
for no reason just for the sake of keeping you
within the ecosystem um you know whether it's
like cash back or governance tokens or things
like that i'm often just like you don't really
need it you know what i mean um so i i do get
frustrated um but you have a card coming as
well isn't is that correct yes yeah so can
you tell me about the card uh yeah well as
much as we can uh yeah there's always like it's
always like you can and you can't really save it
uh yes we've got the card um coming soon which
will effect would be like a debit card back to
your coin corner account um so that'd be like
instantly spendable from your bitcoin balance
um we're hoping that comes um before
the end of the year but um still some
regulatory pieces that we're just getting in
place at the minute um so once they're done
um we'll have a bit more information and
announcements for that um but yeah it's uh
effective bitcoin back to gbp we'll also have
a euro one as well coming with a euro one might
come into the uh new year more than maybe q2
next year um so yeah looking forward to that
and are there any more updates that you can
tell us we know we've got the loans coming
we've got the cards coming you've
currently got the cash back
which is very very cool i've been using that
and enjoying that good that's good here um
we have the kids accountable oh yes this is what i
wanted to ask you actually so tell us you have you
have like this kids savings account coming explain
yeah i don't know like well me and dave are both
parents dave's got three kids i don't even know
i've got three kids yeah everybody really likes it
i might not mention it tells us that he has three
kids people don't understand three i've got one
yeah exactly um yeah i don't know i
guess like i think i've asked for it
previously i think it's i think it's a
great idea um because when my son was born i
bitcoin was something i wanted to buy for him
but then it's like at the moment i just buy
bitcoin and keep it my own account there's no
differentiating between the account so he just
it's just all mashed into one um and i know i
have a bank account with a savings account for
him which is like under his name and separate and
that's kind of what i wanted for us guys as well
i know a lot of other parents i've spoken
to yeah no i don't like them but i i got
my kids on paper wallets those are very
insecure they're in the baby that's amazing
but it's just like anyone could just clean
them out i've not emptied them it was i pretty
so i've been after it for a while there somewhere
like molly says somewhere to keep it organized
and separate so you know how much bitcoin each
one of your kids has got and maybe not giving
well definitely not given access to for a while
but just just to get them on the first rung if
you will yeah of course yeah so yeah i'm super
excited about that um you guys are working on
at the moment yeah we hope that again that'll be
another one before the end of the year it's a lot
before the end of this year yeah i think it's kind
of important though because everybody talks about
bitcoin for the next generation and generational
wealth um so i think i think it's going to be
something that people will like yeah yeah it's
definitely something that's underserved in
in the industry the minute i don't think there's
i've never actually seen one i haven't i haven't
that's like a that's like a physical one yeah
yeah that means kids but yeah confusing so
yeah definitely something that's underserved and
like zach says that you know you talk about um a
generational wealth of bitcoin savings and that's
what people's mentality is and to pass it on to
people so you know that it makes perfect sense
and so certainly underserved and hopefully we can
come and help serve that area sector industry
that that or public that want that product um
soon uh other than that we have the lightning
stuff which we will announce at coinfest um
it's not that far away but we will be
announcing it out by the first day don't worry
um so that'd be quite cool it'll be an
exciting product um hopefully a world
first one as well i think right i'm excited
i'm excited to hear how it all goes but no
i think you know molly you're right when you
say that we always talk about getting the next
generation um into bitcoin um but nobody's really
building anything to really allow that to happen
um so yeah i think i think that's going to be
great um so guys do you have any last final um
things to announce um before we we say goodbye how
can people um join coincorner and follow everyone
where can they find us um all on twitter mostly
yeah socials yeah twitter mainly we're very active
on twitter we're very accessible yeah we ever
have any issues with our platform you can dm
that's true or me or dave or nothing yeah i do
try not to help you don't bother unless you are
um yeah that's one of the things i we it's
frustrating again in the industry as a whole
and it feels like the world these days not
even just our industry like customer service
side of things has been terrible um over the years
yeah from a lot of companies and you know i'm not
saying coincorn is amazing and we're immune to
that in any way whatsoever and what i am saying
though is something that we want to focus on going
forwards and particularly is customer experience
and customer service going through and that's part
of the team being public on socials on twitter
and easy access to anybody at the company that you
need to talk to you know you don't see that from
you know think of any other companies out there
in the world there's very few like you know
take google take microsoft take whoever
you know you can't just jump onto
a social media platform like twitter and dm
the team there and have the communication
that you need and obviously as you know if we
get to the google microsoft size of the company
of course it gets more difficult to be able
to do that don't get me wrong i'm not naive
in that respect um but you know it's
customer service is something that we want to
excel at um for the industry as a whole uh
helping the education side for um our customers
and all the customers uh all the um bitcoins
out there so um so yeah that's where we are
where we hang out and easily accessible come and
dm me if we don't respond instantly give it time
awesome time uh sometimes i think
myself and molly get uh overwhelmed
with messages coming in um so yeah we will reply
he just sometimes takes a little bit of time
yeah i think having that social media presence
is so important i'm always talking about this
and i think you know like the way we started
this conversation off was talking about how
much credibility um it provides and often
with the traditional financial system
it's hard to you know get in touch with someone
and that kind of relationship just isn't there
um so i think having that kind of peer-to-peer
touch um when it comes to customer service in
our community is really important um so guys
i want to thank you so much for coming on
um everyone please follow coincorner and
also check out their cashback service
it is amazing um they i think on jd sports i
bought some shoes and i got like four percent
cash back or something um in bitcoin so yeah
check that out it's really cool even boots as well
contact lenses um yeah i've just bought it with
it with a bunch of different stuff so um check
that out it's a browser extension so yeah take a
look cool thank you good to have you on and guys
don't forget to um tune in next week for another
conversation about bitcoin we'll see you then